guys are you ready are you ready for the
hottest take of all time i don't i don't
think you're actually ready so just
brace yourself all right here it comes
demon slayer
is
giving an opinion about the shonen anime
is kind of like walking into the ghetto
in the middle of the gang war and
expecting not to get lynched you say a
show is great you get blue in the [ __ ]
up you say a show is trash you get beat
the [ __ ] up you say you like your
character you get beat in the [ __ ] up
you say you don't like your character
you get beat the [ __ ] up you say your
show is okay you will get a hit put on
you and everyone around you as all your
closest acquaintances will be
assassinated one by one as you're forced
to look on in despair as everyone you've
ever loved will pay the consequence for
your dumb stupid actions that you've
brought upon the world
and then you get beaten the [ __ ] up so
anyway
i just watched the new demon slayer
yep i'm gonna be a normie today and talk
about demon slayer but before that i'd
like to give a quick shout out to
today's sponsor square enix and near
reincarnation near reincarnation is the
first mobile entry to the legendary near
series this is a free-to-play action
command rpg from square enix and aptly
bots available in the app store and the
google play store coming from legendary
creative director yokotaro composer
keiichi okabe and producer yosuke saito
this is an action command rpg that
features a turn-based battle system
allowing you to build a team of unique
characters and customisable loadouts to
battle against powerful enemies
featuring a fast-paced battle system
with top quality graphics and beautiful
soundtrack immerse yourself in the deep
story of near reincarnation i mean come
on it's on yokotaro you know it's going
to be absolutely bonkers not only that
but until march 14th pst they are also
having a collaboration with nier
automata this is your chance to get 2b
a2 and 9s as playable characters to help
you fight against the enemies but you
also have a chance to get 2p theo and
akiha costumes right now you can enjoy
an original story featuring
near-automatic characters only available
during this collaboration and you can
clear crossover events to earn medals to
exchange for event exclusive items
there's also going to be a global
celebration of the japanese first
anniversary until march 9th when players
can receive a bunch of rewards and
bonuses so what are you waiting for dive
into the madness of the latest near
series by clicking the link in the
description and giving it a go today
thank you to square enix for sponsoring
this video and let's get back to demon
slayer demon slayer is a series that has
completely blown away my expectations on
just how popular it would get season 1
episode 19 broke the internet the manga
sold like a bajillion more volumes than
the previous undisputed king one piece
the movie became the top grossing anime
movie of all time all time here in japan
it is full-on mainstream with every
single age range alike and it just keeps
breaking records left right and center i
knew as with every shonen battle series
i was probably going to get popular but
since my last video i don't think it's
an understatement to say that it's
become a worldwide sensation and the
question that's always been on my mind
is
why i spent a good amount of time trying
to rationalize it in my head doing some
sherlock holmes level brain expansion
deductive reasoning piecing together all
the possible reasons all the little
nuances combing through the smallest
details trying to justify what sets it
apart this much for it to have the
impact that it does around the world and
then i watched season two and i was like
oh
it's just cause the show [ __ ] slaps
demon slayers entertainment district arc
is some of the most pure undistilled
hype i've ever had the pleasure to
experience in the shonen genre no crazy
complicated power systems or five head
battle strategies just pure
hype i'm going to assume you've already
seen the new season in this video
because let's be honest you're not here
to listen to me to help you decide
whether you should be watching it
because you probably already are it's
freaking demon slayer and i just wanted
to gush about it because we have one
thing we can thank for that
studio ufo table you know just a while
ago i might have been just a little bit
just a tiny bit salty [ __ ] when mugen
train had beaten out the likes of
mushoka tensei in the animation
department in the anime awards because i
thought it was unfair that a movie level
production was being compared to a tv
series but the entertainment district
arc showed me that ufo table don't give
a flying [ __ ] about movie level
production when everything they do now
is apparently movie level quality this
is better than season one better than
their own movie better than and it hurts
me to say this possibly anything else
they've worked on so far look you know
me i would die defending fate if i
needed to ask for a body pillar in hand
and all and i'm going to take a moment
to tell you to go [ __ ] watch the
heavens fear movies because it is the
studio at the top of their game but as
much as i love fate there is also a lot
of this
when we see amazing fight sequences it
normally only lasts a few minutes even
demon slayer season 1 revolved around
one short explosive moment of animation
that ended the fight but season 2 gave
us like six episodes in a row of high
intensity squeaky bum full nut action
that rivaled and sometimes even exceeded
the [ __ ] you see in movie level
productions in a tv series what they've
done here is absolutely [ __ ] insane
and this wasn't just your typical flashy
no choreography action there was some
really cool [ __ ] going on one of the
highlights for me was just seeing how
they portrayed a battle on multiple
fronts normally when you have a team
battle in anime it's not really a team
battle but a series of individual fights
matchups are separated battles don't
interfere with one another geologically
they might not even be near each other
entire fights will be segmented by
episodes so it's crystal clear who's
fighting who but this was nothing like
that attacks weave in from one
battlefield to another strikes will come
in tandem or separate depending on the
ebb and flow of things characters
actually switch targets depending on the
state of the fight it felt like the
battle itself had a life of its own it
was organic it was constantly moving
constantly changing this actually felt
like one massive battle with a ton of
smaller moving parts making it up this
is what a spectacle of the highest
degree looks like mainstream or not i
gotta give respect when respect is due
the visuals were out of this world the
sound design gave life to every attack
the music send chills down my spine the
story was
solid
alright here we go look at this guy
enjoying demon slayer watch this i'm
about to end his entire career demon
slayer more like deep mid slayer
when christ himself resurrected from the
dead performing an impossible miracle
for the world to see shonen fans were
like yeah that was mid anytime i even
mentioned demon slayer i actually gotta
mute the thread because of the amount of
[ __ ] being thrown from every angle and
the amount of people acting like they
have massive [ __ ] because they can call
a popular show everyone else likes mid i
don't know what this obsession is with
the shonen community in particular with
calling other popular shonen series mid
like the only breathing technique
they've learned from demon slayer is
huffing copium because how the [ __ ] does
this count as mid all i'm saying is if
you want to see mid try being an isekai
fan you merely adopted the mid we were
born in it moulded in it i didn't see my
first good anime until i stopped
crossing the road yes demon slay isn't a
complex narrative political heavyweight
like attack on titan is right now but it
doesn't try or need to be tanjiro
inosuke zenitsu they might not have an
ocean level amount of depth to them but
they fill the exact role they need to
just like every new character introduced
tengen had some big shoes to fill coming
after rengoku still with the show but i
think he was the perfect guy to do it
yes he's a hashera yes he's confident
and powerful but he's always so aware
about his own limits he has his own
people he looks up to he respects he
knows he's not the greatest or strongest
demon slayer to ever live and it was
just really humbling to see a man who
had accepted that he wasn't the star
that shone the brightest which made him
shine even more like the dude just seems
like a chill bro you'd hang out with
hell i'd like to buy my pint okay and
now he's cancelled you can spend an
eternity picking apart the plot
conveniences or characters but at the
end of the day i watch shonen anime for
the moments that make my jaw drop on the
floor and demon slayer made me open my
jaw so wide a jojo fan would have
thought i'd just finish sucking a
thousand dicks because i think what
shines about demon slayer is its
simplicity a lot of people like to say
well demon slayer wouldn't be as good if
it wasn't for the animation yes and
berserk wouldn't be one of the most
beautifully illustrated manga of all
time if it was drawn by a drunk ape
writing characters world building power
systems it doesn't necessarily go above
and beyond compared to some of its
counterparts but it doesn't really need
to when it delivers this hard in the
moments that matter it's doing exactly
what it needs to do without complicating
[ __ ] when you get to this level of
popularity this fast it isn't the
intricate nuances that play the biggest
factor it's how well you can execute the
simple stuff your grandma walks in and
you watching other shows and she asks
what's that and you have to explain well
you see grandma this kid's trying to
find his dad so then use their nen which
is a power to transport them into a
video game which isn't really a video
game to find clues and now they're
playing a game of volleyball because
that's one of his dad's friends who may
or may not know where his dad is except
everyone also has super powers like he
can use rock paper scissors he can use
electricity and then there's also a
clown who can turn his energy into
bungee gum so your grandma goes i don't
get it
i really hope your grandma doesn't sound
like this as opposed to when she walks
in you watching demon slayer and you go
oh well this guy's a demon slayer and
this guy's a demon and he's trying to
slice his head off so your grandma goes
[ __ ] them demons you got the good guys
you got the bad guys the bad guys lose
when the good guys slice their head off
it's so simple your grandma can follow
along and so every fight is just one
massive build up for this single moment
and demon slayer pushes this build up to
the absolute limit of intensity the
second half of the entertainment
district arc is just a big lead up to
one massive crescendo no amount of lube
in the world could prepare my anus for
the pure unadulterated hype that would
be entering it some of these scenes came
with such intensity that i forgot i knew
my own breathing technique called um
well breathing there were some moments
that literally took my breath away and
it was only after the moment had passed
that i remembered to take a deep breath
to take in the sheer orgasmic energy i
just experienced and double check that i
hadn't ejaculated in the process forget
the simple storyline forget the bible
book shonen formula because there are
only few shows that are ever able to
make me do that and that's the real
reason i wanted to make this video i
didn't need to tell you guys demon
slayer was a good show i didn't need to
tell you guys to go watch it because by
god you probably already are i wanted to
acknowledge when i see something being
taken to the next level because that's
what i think ufo table have done for a
tv animated series what we are seeing
here is a team who's reached the peak of
their craft not one who's gotten there
by shortcuts but one who's carefully
honed it through years of trials and
tribulations demon slayer feels like the
culmination of ufo table perfecting
their work through a decade of hard work
there was no easy way to get to this
point no shortcut to be taken and
something like this wouldn't be possible
without a team motivated enough to keep
constantly pushing themselves to achieve
even greater heights with every new show
they take on there are only a select few
anime studios out there that seemingly
come with a permanent seal of quality a
studio like this not only set the bar of
quality they are the bar of quality and
no matter how ridiculously high we think
they may set that bar somehow they find
a way to exceed themselves with every
new project i called the episode 19
scene a work of art for just how
masterfully crafted that segment was and
ufo table continued to deliver above and
beyond with every passing season moments
so intense so deeply immersing that i've
run out of superlatives i can possibly
say it's incredible
it's a masterclass it's a new standard
for anime
[Music]
[Music]
you